Sindbad certainly can't catch a break,
but perhaps we can catch or notice errors in Python programs.
If we are very wary and think that an error might happen,
we can use the Python keywords try and except to guard critical code.
This code is guarded.
And if an error happens in here instead of aborting Python execution,
it will go down to this except block and start executing there.
This except block only runs if the guarded block has an error.
So this code will print out "hello"
and then we've seen before that when we try to do integer division by 0
that doesn't make much sense, so we'll jump down here and print out "didn't work"
and then print out problem, which was our particular exception.
And if you haven't run into it before, exception is just a special computer science keyword
meaning an error in a program.
It derives from exceptional situation and can refer to either something like
you're out of space on your disk or memory card
or a problem in your program like you're trying to divide by 0.
However, it's also entirely possible to raise exceptions on our own.
So here in this Python code fragment we're printing out "joseph heller"
but in the middle we raise this exception with the value 22.
And then down here we catch that exception, calling it the variable problem,
and then we print out, oh, it "didn't work: we caught" problem,
and this will end up printing out "joseph".
We'll raise the exception,
so we'll never actually print out "heller".
We will print out it "didn't work: we caught" 22.
And Catch-22 is a satirical novel by Joseph Heller. It's a bit absurd.
The phrase "catch-22" has actually entered the popular English lexicon,
meaning, approximately, "no win situation."